Speaker 1: OK, a few other updates here.
South Dakota has seen cases quintuple,
quintuple, quintuple after the Sturgis motorcycle
rally two weeks after the annual motorcycle rally
in Sturgis, South Dakota, reported covid
infections in the state have risen nearly
six fold. It's a very unsurprising headline.
South Dakota counted more than 3800 new cases
in two weeks, including seven deaths, up from only
six hundred forty four cases in the previous two
weeks. That makes it the state with the largest
percent increase in covid in the past two weeks.
The state's rate of covid infections per capita
in the last two weeks is in the bottom half of the
country. But it's the sharp and sudden increase in
case counts that sets it apart. Moeed County, home
to Sturgis, has counted 330 new cases in the last
two weeks. This is a really low population place,
so three hundred and thirty cases is a lot up from
the 20 reported in the two weeks before the rally.
So, look, think about that number. The two weeks
before the rally, Mead County has 20 covid cases
in the two weeks after the rally made county has
330 covid cases. That's according to the Johns
Hopkins University case count. The 15 150 percent
increase comes after the motorcycle rally, which
usually draws half a million people, possibly had
its biggest year ever, according to County Sheriff
Ron Merwyn. And as you can see, we're putting
up a map on the screen and I'll describe the
map to you. The map is of all 50 U.S. states. And
what you see is that there is one dark red state,
that state of South Dakota, and that is where we
have seen a four hundred and ninety three percent
increase over two weeks. Some of the other
darker red states include nearby North Dakota,
up about one hundred and twenty four percent.
West Virginia, which is up I'm not exactly sure
what percent. Indiana is looking pretty red, up
about 99 percent. And the latest color states,
California and Nevada, as well as Missouri and
Louisiana. So that's what's going on there. And
it is a completely unsurprising headline. There's
also the question of whether we're going to see
similar numbers in Alabama. Remember Donald
Trump on Saturday holding a rally in Cullman,
Alabama, and Alabama, the worst second to worse
health infrastructure in the United States.
Education is also terrible. In Mississippi
and Alabama, vaccination rates are very
low in Mississippi and Alabama. And so we'll see
whether we're going to get more cases there. Now,
I know some of you will be saying, hold on a
second, David. Sir, you always talk about how
outdoors is really not a big deal. And mostly that
is correct. As we've talked about, even before,
we had vaccines, only about one out of a thousand
covid cases was being transmitted outdoors.
But that one out of a thousand was happening when
people were doing obviously stupid things that
they shouldn't be doing, like massing together
by the thousands. And so if you are going to
see case transmission outdoors, it's going to be
in situations like the Trump rally in Cullman,
Alabama, where nobody was wearing masks, people
were massed together for some people got their 12
hours, 10, nine, 10 hours before the rally. And
we're going to see we'll track the numbers two
weeks before and two week after two weeks after
Trump's rally in Alabama. But it is not looking
good and people doing really dumb things, and I
don't expect it to change anytime soon. Sadly,